the main difficulties of working with
any vulnerable or fragile work of
cultural heritage is the respect you
have to have for that object technology
is at a point right now where we can
record the surface of an object down to
fractions of a millimeter and it's
through this kind of understanding that
allows you to communicate across time
and across cultures and the task of
heritage protection and preservation is
a real challenge
the mission of factum foundation is to
record cultural heritage so in the event
that there's a disaster or an accident
we have the data to know what was there
exactly as it is we're pioneering a
number of methods to return that
information into the physical world
we're doing CNC milling we're doing 3d
printing but we're trying to go beyond
that a facsimile of the Borg are in each
Apple the facsimile of the tomb of
Tutankhamen in the Valley of the Kings
an exact facsimile of Vera nasals
wedding at Cana
[Music]
[Applause]
the biggest project that's going on at
the moment is an exact facsimile of the
tomb of Seti the first which will be
given to the people of Egypt as soon as
it's finished two hundred years ago the
concern was not one of preservation the
concern was one of Indiana Jones and
discovery and excitement and cultural
acquisitions the tombs in the Valley of
the Kings lasted successfully for three
thousand three and a half thousand years
but since they've been visited they
start to decline and decay rapidly
I think the facsimile is opening up a
whole new level of possibility for
display preservation conservation
restoration communication dissemination
of what's important about these objects
if only we can preserve it like it is
and document it and hand it on to future
generations then there's hope
[Music]